going back to what you're saying about
how this this had a really weird [__]
dungeon but going back to what you're
saying about how there are some people
who can appreciate something by knowing
everything about that particular thing
do you find that to you the more you
learn about something the less you
appreciate it or the more you appreciate
it more I appreciate it really yeah
nearly always
I don't know why I just the more I learn
about something the more I am I get
excited about the small details and I
think that's something I'm really happy
that I suppose I have I didn't realize
yeah I'd be happy for that but then yeah
because it's it's really easy yeah it's
really weird because uh I've thought of
some people like you that you know the
more they learn about certain things the
more I love it really really appreciate
I love learning yeah because for me it's
like uh for me it's like a two-way
street because in one sense I do it does
help me gain a bigger appreciation let's
say like there's an anime and I learn
about the behind the scenes about how it
was made the animators that did some
certain cuts it makes me appreciate the
art form more and it makes me appreciate
the art form deeper but at the same time
I can never enjoy this anime in the same
way ever again it's it's super weird I
kind of get what wait wait
the magic disappears it's like the it's
like the veil has been uncovered and the
magic just disappears yeah it's yeah
yeah yeah yeah what it's like uh you so
you believe like in your head is it like
this anime is in like some kind of Realm
of magic where it's like I don't know
how it's made it's awesome no no it's
it's like the I guess the best way I can
describe it is
um so there is this very very famous
animator right he's called Yutaka
Nakamura and if you've watched any big
Shonen you have probably seen some of
his work you don't know you've seen his
work but you've seen some of his works
because he has a very distinct animation
style and he animates some of the most
hype scenes in all of anime is he the
guy that does the block experience yeah
the block explosions yeah so I I had no
idea but I had no idea about it um about
like the old animation scene and I
remember the first time I learned about
this I was like holy [__] this guy this
guy's the goat he's the goat and he's
like he's like he looked at all his
works I'm like this guy's freaking
amazing and then I remember I was
watching uh one new anime probably like
my hero Academia season two and I was
like super super invested in uh Todoroki
versus that fight was amazing yeah
versus Deku that was [__] incredible
I was like immersed and then in like the
most hype moment I saw his like
animation style I saw his cubes and I it
went from holy [__] I'm invested in this
fight scene to oh look it's a it's it's
a Yutaka Nakamura cup I knew that and it
like it just took took me out of that
moment in that just just because I knew
I've been just because there was
something I recognized and something
like like I said the veil had been
uncovered and I was like ah it's it's
that thing I learned I think like a good
like comparison is like you know if
you're watching like a magic show right
and it's like you're watching the magic
show and you're seeing this magician do
do this trick and you're like holy [__]
like that was incredible that was a
great trick my mind was blown and then
you learn how the trick was done yeah
right and it's this two-way of like you
appreciate now how much effort these
magicians go to like you know yeah do
the trick and and you know show the
illusion but then you can never see that
trick in the same way again yeah I think
I think that's like kind of the
comparison with that if that makes sense
so would this be like a further question
would this be like your first viewing of
that scene or is this like the second
view this would be my first viewing now
that now that I've recognized the style
I guess right I it it like took me out
of the magic because I know I guess the
person behind this
um and so it instead of being invested
in the actual show it just took me out
for a moment just to just because like
now you're thinking about that animator
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
would you feel the same way when you see
an actor you know in another new role
for a TV series or a movie you watch
theoretically it's the same kind of vibe
right it looks like if you see Leonardo
DiCaprio in another film you're like
well yeah obviously not really Cabrio I
can't invest myself in this no I I think
I think it's slightly different I think
it's more akin to ah
because to me to me an actor is a
completely different job like a
completely right right
um it's it's not in the exactly the same
way with the behind the scenes of how it
was made because to me like the actor is
I guess
he's
he's like a different product in every
movie right and it's their job to invest
me in the character that they're playing
right
um and after I learn about what they go
through with their roles and everything
for some reason that doesn't ruin it for
me yeah
um but sometimes when I when I know I
think it would be more accurate to say
if I know there's a certain director
and I know a director has a certain
style and I really when I was young I
don't know why I like this director I
don't know why I really like Quentin
Tarantino movies for example uh and then
I grow older and I realized oh it's
because of the way he does dialogue or
because like characters are written this
way and as soon as I notice the style or
the pattern yeah and then I see it in
his future works it's kind of like oh I
know the secret to the trick now it's I
I still think you can almost foresee
I still think it's incredible but
there's some magic there that's so
stressed I think it's I think I think it
works with like animation or like you
know uh like magic or like you know
directors and stuff like that because
like the what you're viewing is the art
yeah and not the artist whereas with an
actor the artist is the art yeah right
so it's I think it's this distinction of
like if you know about the artist who is
not at the Forefront of whatever your
view or experiencing then it kind of
creates two different viewpoints that
can distract you from either one if that
makes sense whereas if you're if you're
looking at an actor right because what
because who they are is what you are
seeing it's it's harder to kind of build
that distinction between the two okay I
think another question yeah when you
listen to an anime like you also made in
abyss and then the soundtrack sounds
amazing you're like man I just picture
Kevin
making I do does that does that ruin
your enjoyment or change it in any way
for me when I watched Men to be season
two yeah right and you hear Kevin's
music in it yeah it's [__] incredible
right it sounds amazing I'm invested in
the story but then the musician side of
me is like oh yeah I think I know how he
made this and I kind of wanted to and it
distracts me being like okay so he wrote
the song kind of like this and now all
I'm thinking about is the creation
process that Kevin went through yeah to
make this particular scene and now I am
distracted from actually watching the
episode yeah okay okay yeah not all the
time are you the same then I would say
this is I'm just gonna big up my boy for
a second uh I think Kevin does a really
incredible job at having trying
different different and new things in
all of his works so he he has I I would
say I don't know if he's still
discovering his style but he's doing a
lot of weird [__]
um so what happens is I watch a scene
I'm like totally invested and then I
like snap out I'm like wait where the
[__] it that little [__] made this
what the [__] man how the [__] did he
make this that's so weird that I guess
you see it that way because when I'm
when I'm watching stuff I just don't I
don't even like I just watch it and I
know that it's maybe this person or
something yeah but I just I just don't
think about it like I'm just I'm just
focused on the show so much that yeah I
don't you know it's like when you hear
like I guess a voice actor you recognize
right because that's so it's not not
even the appearance right it's the voice
it's like oh like yeah I I don't I more
so I kind of like seeing how maybe that
person is trying this character or I
like seeing how they do it it's like
ultimately everyone is trying their own
take on something right and I feel like
if you start thinking about it too much
about who's doing what and oh it's their
style oh it's this is their style oh
this is them trying this I feel like
you're so lost I try not to get
distracted but I think there's a tiny
part in the back of your head that's
like conscious that it says yeah I mean
I mean to to say I don't wanna I don't
want my mind to work like that I'm just
saying that is just how my mind yeah
it's it's like like going back to the
Leonardo DiCaprio thing it's less about
Leonardo DiCaprio but if I kind of I
guess learn more about acting techniques
and you know different models
yeah something then yes I would be very
distracted in what he's doing on screen
because he's like oh he's doing that I
feel like you'd just be watching it
differently like you're just you know I
would say you're getting distracted it's
like you're watching it in a different
way than I'm watching it yeah yeah you
are you are definitely watching it
differently and I do like I said
appreciate I I appreciate it in a
different way but it's not the same kind
of enjoyment well it's like the
difference between watching a movie and
watching a movie with director's
commentary right like it's it's still
enjoyable but in a completely different
aspect no I don't want to watch
directors commentary really I [__] do
not want oh I mean I've I've I used to
think that but then I've seen some like
directors commentaries of movies I
really really enjoyed that I've seen
multiple times and and it's like because
I already know the movie and I already
know the subject material yeah watching
the director's commentary of that movie
I know back to front gives me like
another layer of enjoyment yeah where
it's like now I know the inner workings
of this movie and what they were
thinking about with particular scenes
and like that gives me appreciation now
on a completely different level because
the only time I've ever watched tractors
commentaries through the YouTube shorts
or Tick Tock
those are the breaking bad ones because
they filter out all the other stuff that
is is boring yeah a lot of the times
there's you know they're not saying
anything or they're talking about
something completely unrelated yeah yeah
all right well I don't care what Mike
the sound guy was talking about like
yeah well that wouldn't be a director
yeah well no because they'll be like no
I don't know it's in like they'll be
like because Andreas commentaries will
always go on tangents yeah like we do
yeah yeah where they talk about
something or something someone else on
the set did that you don't you have no
connection to it you're like what the
[__] is this that's just a bad director
of this commentary a lot of them suck
though because a lot of the times it's
not the director that wants to do this
like well we have a DVD we've got to add
something in to give it a little
something yeah of course can you can you
just watch that movie and talk over it
yeah and they're like okay sure fine all
right if it sells one of the copies you
know so I feel like it's not even those
are so boring a lot of the time because
they just come from a place of necessity
not from a place of actually like
passionate about it like on on like the
flip side though there are some times
where finding out the behind the scenes
can make me appreciate something that I
didn't really appreciate in the first
place yeah [__] uh seeing I was
seeing Avatar Two behind the scenes yeah
I mean it's crazy holy [__] it's like
I'm it's almost like too much you're
like this seems like way too much effort
for what you got yeah yeah it's it's
made me appreciate Avatar too even
[__] I I actually find behind the
scenes of Avatar 2 more interesting how
they made Avatar is way more interesting
than Avatar yeah I mean every time I
talk to Kevin about like you know stuff
he did for me in abyss and like Tower of
God it's like that just makes me
appreciate that sound even more now yeah
but at the same time the next time I
watch tower of God I'm gonna have the
back of my mind being like Oh okay so
this is what Kevin was talking about
with this particular track you know I
don't want to get distracted with it but
it's gonna be in the back of my head
somewhere I did have a moment [__] with
Maiden Abyss too actually oh it was it
was
it was I can't remember the exact scene
of the track but I just remember I just
remember uh uh it was one it was one of
the intense scenes in the uh latter half
of me in the best season two there was
this dramatic scene coming on and then
out of nowhere Kevin there's just this
like this synthesizer solo just comes in
and I'm just like for [__] sake Kevin
just like all the flashback of the Kevin
episode just come full force you just
imagine camera just [__] yeah all
those hours of Kevin talking about
synthesizers has led to this moment I'm
like [__] sake he does love this [__]
he does yeah he very much does